thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be here at Hillsdale College today
before Hillsdale supporters and and
professors and students and I I want to
say future employees and interns of the
America First policy
Institute we love Hillsdale we love the
the competent and well-educated and
hardworking students you're sending uh
uh Mary CLA Hamilton who who who was an
intern at afpi she's here to today and
uh I I I can't keep track of how many
Hillsdale students were hiring but
please keep them
coming uh I've been asked to speak today
about the importance of good
intelligence but I want to say upfront
that I'm going to talk about the bad and
the good because I think we have to
understand the bad to get to and to
promote the good a and um as you just
heard I've been with intelligence for a
long time I've worked as an intelligence
producer as an analyst I've worked as a
consumer and a job at the state
department I worked in intelligence
production uh at the CIA I've worked in
intelligence oversight uh so I've looked
at intelligence from every W every
possible angle I think you know that
intelligence is in trouble today because
of allegations some of them proven of
serious misconduct by us intelligence
agencies and Personnel this includes
attempting to interfere in two
presidential elections promoting a false
narrative that the Trump campaign
colluded with Russia using this false
narrative to justify spying on the Trump
campaign multiple leaks of classified
intelligence to undermine members of the
Trump campaign and the Trump
administration politization of
intelligence assessments to hurt the
Trump campaign and to bolster the B
Administration there's also been
allegations of us intelligence agencies
violating the Privacy rights of the
American people this includes
allegations that the national Security
Agency inappropriately access the phone
data of Americans and unmas the redacted
names of trump campaign officials from
NSA reports and gave them to Obama
officials which they exploited for
political purposes and recently a DHS
cyber office has been accused of trying
to investigate and censor
conservatives misconduct by American
intelligence agencies is not new these
agencies meddled in domestic politics
before
including in 2004 for example in 2004
the wal Journal ran an editorial
entitled the CIA Insurgency that the
journal claimed was trying to work
behind the scenes to prevent President
Bush from being reelected and I say this
because many of my friends who worked in
the Trump Administration mistakenly
think that the CIA and other
intelligence agencies they they they
became out of control because of the
Trump Administration but that isn't true
and I think many of you know that but
the these allegations are much more
serious because they've caused many
Americans and members of Congress to
demand that intelligence agencies be
curtailed or shut down well look I know
that America's intelligence agencies
produce good intelligence every day to
keep our nation safe and free I I know
that the vast majority of Intelligence
Officers are not political and get no
Public Credit for the public credit for
the work they do to protect our country
some of them at some of them risk in
their
lives one example is the 2016 Heritage
Foundation report that found 80 islamist
terrorist plots against the US between
2001 and 2016 most of them were stopped
by good intelligence and I'm sure there
are many many more of these plots since
2016 many other intelligence excess
successes have protected our security
suum you know about suum can never be
made public I am therefore for improving
reforming and depoliticizing America's
intelligence agencies not doing away
with
them but these recent developments are
very dangerous because they've
undermined the reputation of the US
intelligence Community as objective as
and trustworthy if presidents senior us
officials and members of Congress become
so distrustful of American intelligence
and disregarded as some kind of
left-wing political institutions
spouting liberal propaganda they may
refuse to listen to intelligence
analysts when these analysts are trying
to get these officials urgent
intelligence to protect our nation
security regardless of its flaws it is
crucial in this incredibly dangerous
world with growing threat threats from
America's enemies that we have a capable
and robust and trustworthy intelligence
service to defend against and warn
against threats to our security and
freedom I want to pause here and Define
some terms first of all what is in
intelligence well intelligence is
information but for the purpose of the
US intelligence Community we might in we
might Define intelligence as the
collection and processing of information
on foreign countries to Aid in the
crafting and implementation of national
security policies and the conduct of
covert operations abroad to facilitate
the implementation of these policies
it's important to note that intelligence
is not always collected secretly and
it's not always classified a great deal
of the intelligence that intelligence
analysts use is open- Source information
and today an awful lot of that
information comes from the internet a
second important question is what is the
purpose of us intelligence agencies this
is a more difficult one to
answer the CIA says on its website we
collect and analyze foreign intelligence
and conduct covert action US policy
makers including the president of the
United States make policy decision
decisions informed by the information we
provide CIA and other Intelligence
Officers also often say that their job
is to speak truth to
power CI director Michael Hayden and I
might add he he's one of the officials
who signed that letter the 51 Former
Intelligence Officers we will get into
that went further in 2010 when he said
policy makers are the vision people in
National Security and intelligence
officers are the fact people Hayden
explained that he believes the policy
Visions by decision makers are often
realistic and need to be offset by the
facts provided by intelligence agencies
well let's let's stop here because let's
stipulate that intelligence agencies and
reports are usually not facts whether
they're raw intelligence or analysis and
they're often wrong moreover although an
intelligence analyst assessment of a
national security issue is supposed to
be neutral and objective and
non-political and credible often it is
not but really the bottom line here is
that intelligence analysis conclusions
are opinions of intelligence agencies
they are not facts and they're
frequently wrong and despite what you
hear from the mainstream media and and
and liberal academics and members of
Congress presidents are not requireed
ired to abide by what intelligence
agencies tell them their analysis is not
binding on a president if he thinks you
know with good reason that a piece of
intelligence intelligence analys is
biased or he has another good source
he's not obligated to let these agencies
make up his mind to tell him what to do
Hayden also thinks that the OS
intelligence Community has a social
contract with the American people
according to Hayden this means us
intelligence agencies have to earn that
trust by acting as our fellow citizens
who expect us to skillfully boldly and
always in keeping with the laws and
values of our
Republic related to this belief and this
is sort of
incredible and this is something you
hear a lot in the mainstream media and
you hear from many Former Intelligence
Officers it's a belief that it's the job
of us intelligence agencies to
adjudicate US national security
questions this even includes a belief
that us intelligence agencies act as a
check on presidential National Security
decisions we saw this in 2019 when CI
director Gina haspel and Director of
National Intelligence Dan coats told an
open hearing of the Senate and
intelligence committee that President
Trump's policies on the Iranian and
North Korean nuclear programs were
likely to
fail I remember this well president
Trump was understandably angry at what
haspel and coach said about his policies
especially because was his staff was
finalizing plans at the time for a
second Trump Kim Summit in Vietnam two
weeks later as a result Trump cancelled
unclassified intelligence hearings for
the remainder of his presidency they
were of course resumed under President
Biden concerning this incident I believe
unclassified worldwide threat briefings
to Congress make no sense it doesn't
matter that intelligence agencies claim
their testimony is unclassified make no
mistake these hearings are providing
valuable intelligence to our enemies on
what our intelligence agencies think
what their priorities are what our
Intelligence Officers think and of
course members of Congress can't help
themselves from using these hearings to
Grand standing before the television
cameras and ask Goa questions to trap
and embarrass the administration and
intelligence agency so I think president
Trump was right unclassified worldwide
threat briefings are an outrage and they
should be permanently
cancelled and of course there is John
Brennan the clownish and deeply partisan
former CI director and now MSNBC analyst
who helped orchestrate the Russia
collusion hoax during 20 the 2016
presidential campaign in explaining the
cia's mission in 2016 Brennan
said you won't believe this it's so
crazy we don't steal Secrets everything
we do is consistent with US law we
uncover we discover we reveal we obtain
we elicit we solicit all of that
well this statement by Brennan who was
the CIA director at the time caused hows
of laughter from current Ander
intelligence professionals this included
CI director director of operations
officer John Maguire who said in
response to Brennan's comment every
aspect of what the CIA does overseas is
illegal we don't solicit secrets we
steal
them what does he call breaking into an
embassy it's absurd on its face and you
can insert your John Brandon joke here
but I'm not going
to given what I just told you about
these activities by American
intelligence agencies one has to wonder
what was their original purpose is it
conceivable the TR that the Truman
Administration the former members of the
office of strategic Services the World
War II pred cessor of the CIA members of
Congress who founded the CIA in the late
1940s would create a standing
post-war civilian intelligence service
that would try to act as a check in
Presidential Power medal in presidential
elections claim it has its own social
contract with the American people is it
conceivable that President Truman would
have agreed to a new intelligence
service that would do any of these
things well of course the answer is no
in his classic book uh the agency the
rise and decline of the CIA John ranala
explained the intended role of the CIA
this way the agency has one main client
the president of the United States who
also is the agency's boss agency people
are the President's Men their basic job
is to find the truth and to tell it to
the president now current law which was
amended in 2000 says something similar
it says the US intelligence communties
mission is to collect and provide
information needed by the president and
in the performance of executive
functions the vice president the NSC the
Homeland Security Council the chairman
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff senior
military commanders other executive
branch officials and as appropriate the
Congress of the United States so let's
be clear the intelligence Community
works for the American people and
Congress through the president it's one
main client it is no business
adjudicating or second guessing
presidential policies it obviously
should not be weaponized against the
president and his administration or be
used to spy on or intimidate American
citizens today's intelligence
agencies to some extent depends on on
the day of the week have lost sight of
their primary mandate to serve the
president and sometimes operate so
independently and arrogantly that they
have been accused of being part of an
unelected layer of government sometimes
called an administrative state or or or
deep State now my friend and colleague
Sam fattis who takes an even more
negative view than me uh we'll be
discussing this later in his
presentation later today I will say that
the American first policy inst to we are
more optimistic we are engaged in an
ambitious project the America First
transition project to help a new
president 2025 take our country back and
get control of the US government on day
one of of the next Administration for
the US intelligence Community this means
depoliticizing the intelligence service
by returning it to its primary mission
of providing high quality and truthful
intelligence to the
president much of my remarks so far have
been sort of negative and it's talked
about how us intelligence has gone wrong
and I want to talk about how I I think
it's succeeded I want to talk about some
of my experiences I was privileged to
work for 19 years as an intelligence
official I was on D
to uh the DIA and state for about six of
those years my typical day as an
intelligence analyst started by turning
on my computer reviewing all the
classified and open source material that
came in overnight and if I saw something
that was current and and Urgent and
topical I would submit them to be
published in the president's Daily Brief
or the National Intelligence daily I
also would incorporate this intelligence
into longer intelligence papers I was
writing my job also included getting out
of the office meeting with intelligence
collectors usually with the CIA director
of operations and NSA I also would meet
with policy makers to determine what
their intelligence needs were this was a
fulfilling job I I I traveled I met a
lot of senior officials I know that the
work that I did played a role in
crafting many uh important US policies
and I received feedback from many
officials including ambassadors and from
presidents Reagan and George HW B Bush
but this job had some challenges some
career is criticize Republican policy
makers for attempting to politicize
intelligence and claimed they would
resist this by speaking truth to power
and occasionally I encountered
pressure